hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game uh from the super bit
chess classic uh
round two it's the first tournament of
the grand chester event uh from 2021 and
it's maxim vashilogra versus uh a
gentleman we saw
in the previous video he fought against
geary he almost won but he missed that
that little trick that was very very
difficult to see
bogdan daniel deck and thank you
everyone for
uh improving my pronunciation of
romanian names i did not know it was dex
so thank you for
that i always enjoy it when you guys uh
write uh
write some like that in the comments
that way i learn and then i know for the
next video and i also said
uh if i mispronounced it in the previous
one that i'm gonna cover at least one
more game
but i would have covered this one all
the same so without further ado let's
check it out uh maxime with the white
pieces opens with e4
and it's uh it's pretty great
opportunity for such a young grandmaster
as this is uh
well his second super super grand master
in a row both maxim
and giri have uh just enjoyed their uh
candidates tournament uh
so you know not not not bad
uh we have e4 e5 knight to f3 knights to
c6 and bishop
that's not a bishop bishop to b5 the
royal lopez is on the board
now we have a6 morphy's defense and now
bishop to a4 and this
most of the opening will be uh something
that we've seen plenty of times
so knight to f6 we have castles and
knight captures on e4 uh
nothing uh out of the ordinary here uh
we have d4
uh and now b5 pushing the bishop back
bishop to b3 and now
d5 we have d captures on e5 and bishop
to e6 so all
this has all been played before many
many times we have knight beat to d2
and now bishop to e7 just continuing
development we have c3 making room for
the bishop on c2 also
nicely controlling this knight on c6 we
have castles
uh and here we have bishop to c2 by
maxine
and now f5 either cementing this knight
uh
on e4 or now if white wants he can
capture alba song
and then black will just capture back
and this is again nothing new
there are almost 300 games in the
database with this exact same position
so e captures an f6 alpha song now this
is a
played a bit less the the the main idea
here was
knight to b3 uh most people play this
but e captures and f6 is also a known
move
so knight captures and now a4 uh
striking on
on the queen side uh there is a very
notable game vladimir ferro save
versus uh vidit from the 2019 world
blitz championship in moscow
but we're gonna mention that a little
bit more so b4
uh challenging this uh c3 pawn uh and
now rook to e1 and here uh there uh
in the game that we've mentioned uh
ferocious versus uh uh video that ferro
sev won
with it played queen to d7 but here we
have bishop to g4 and it is now
as of move 15 that we have a completely
new game so let's see how maxine deals
with
this uh interesting new position so
knight to f1
this is the the standard stuff you can
either push the bishop back with uh with
knight a3 if
if uh this bishop shifts to this
diagonal then you can also play bishop
to e3 the knight will nicely support it
you can play some like h5 bishop h5
knight g3
all depends on what black plays so here
uh the immediate bishop to c5
and now bishop to e3 countering this
bishop
getting ready to capture it and now d4
and
this d4 is a beautiful pawn push but not
the most beautiful pawn push you will
see in this game
uh because it's defended four times by
the pawn by the knight by the bishop and
by the queen so what's the idea here
well one of the defenders is pinned so
that's
there's obviously that so see captures
on d4
we have knight captures on d4 and now
bishop captures on d4 so now before
recapturing first
bishop captures on f3 uh queen captures
and now queen captures on d4 and now
this queen bishop battery here on this
diagonal is very strong
if the sdf two pawn is only defended by
the queen
okay by the king but that doesn't really
count so here we have rook
8 to d1 maxim develops the rook
uh well with deadly tempo he gives up
the b2 pawn and he says i don't i don't
really care about this pawn
and what happens next is a very
interesting because uh
deck decides to capture the pawn and now
it seems that
maksim should have gone for this bishop
captures an h7 idea but he decided
uh that maybe maybe it wasn't all that
great
but it uh seems to be seems to be uh
seems to be possible to do it but also
what maxine played is
uh is fine but this is interesting
because
if bishop captures you can always win
back your piece because the bishop on c5
is undefended for example
uh if knight captures on h7 you're just
gonna play queen to d5 check and then
pick up the bishop so you can do it like
this
or if the king captures an h7 then you
simply play
queen to f5 check and then you pick up
the bishop on c5
so this is one way to win back your pawn
but maksim is not interested in winning
back his pawn maksim simply
improves his position he plays rook to
e2 and now he's threatening bishop
captures on h7 and then uh
he's going to win the queen here so now
we have queen to c3
now offering a queen trade and defending
the bishop on c5 so such ideas are no
longer possible
but here maxim has this very strong rook
to d3 idea
so what can the what can the queen do
well not all that much you have to go
all the way back and
if you try something like queen to c4
then of course bishop b3
just wins the queen you don't want to
fall for something like this so instead
we have queen to a1
and now what do you do here here we have
rook to d1
queen back to c3 rook to d3 queen back
to a1 rook to d1
sorry and maxine was not interested in
repeating the position one more time so
he went for the absolute strongest idea
and that is
g4 and now you can see that um
uh it's it does weaken the white king
and the the
the black pieces are uh somewhat not
doing all that much the queen is
stuck here on a1 the knight can't really
move you don't have any discoveries
because if the knight moves then queen
d5 check is always possible
and well it's uh it's a very interesting
position to say the least so here
uh you might um uh you might uh
play a lot of things uh but uh the the
move that was played in the game is
simply
simply a great one so here if you try to
prevent
the move g5 the idea of g4 is g5 if you
try to do it with something like h6
this loses the game on the spot because
g5 is coming either way
you don't really care about the pawn you
just want to open up the h file and now
if pawn captures
now you play queen to c6 you re-maneuver
the queen here with tempo
uh the bishop is under attack and let's
say the bishop moves
otherwise you're just going to lose a
piece now you play bishop
b3 check king has to move and now rook
to h3 check and that's it
there are no more moves uh your only
defense is knight to h7
and then the idea behind queen coming to
c6 is actually just
shifted over to g6 and there now is no
defense against queen captures an h7
checkmate
so uh while h6 seems like a reasonable
move
it really just loses on the spot so
remember
a few moves ago i said that that pawn
push was only the second
greatest pawn push this game now comes
the greatest spawn push this game and
that's b3 uh this is just
this is just amazing uh because well
what
does what does why do you do now uh it's
very hard for
for white to decide because white really
wanted this bishop on this diagonal
but if you capture with the rook then
you no longer have control of the d4
square then queen to d4 can be played
and now you're now you're in big
problems because now g5 is no longer an
option if g5 you can just shift the
knight over here
now it might be black who's attacking
here uh
it's perfectly playable for white but uh
you know maybe maybe not do something
like that if
if you don't have to so instead after b3
of course you're not going to allow this
pawn to stay alive uh bishop captures on
b3 with
check but this is what uh deck wanted he
wanted to
free up the g8 square for his knight we
have g5 and
now the knight can come to g8 we have
queen to d5 now by maxine
and now bishop to d6 so it's a very
interesting position
and maxime still needs to figure out how
to prove that
this is uh well either better or winning
he plays a rook to h3
and now again a very very dangerous
position
uh point is if you play a weird move
let's say you try something like this
you want to
trade trade some rocks queen d3 and
that's it you resign there's no defense
against this if
you play some like g6 uh we don't care
we can always capture that so
that's not really really an option so
here after rook to h3
the only move for for black that steel
uh still keeps him in the game
that is g6 and here uh maxime
uh had one a very important task he has
to play the absolute best move
and the absolute best move is queen to
e6 now you again threaten this and there
is not
all that much you can do queen to g7 has
to be played and now black is completely
tied down and white will
slowly but surely push and improve his
position however
after g6 maxim played queen to d3 he
attacked the pawn this way
but this allows black for a very uh very
creative maneuver that allows him to
defend and attack simultaneously
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to figure out this
incredible move for black while i give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations uh on spotting
this
uh this beauty and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to f5 and now uh all sorts of
ideas become possible now the you bla
white does not have a threat if white
the queen was here white would still
have a threat
uh but but now even the g5 pawn is
hanging and
there is no way uh uh to do anything
about it
if maxine wanted he could defend it with
queen to e3 then
while black brings the rook into the
game and then it's an extremely passive
position for white it would be black who
would be
just slowly improving the position
whether he would be able to win this
it's hard to say but maksim doesn't want
to suffer
like this maksim would rather give up a
pawn and suffer that way but
at least he wants to have his pieces
active so here
he played a queen to c3 with check he
offered a queen trade
but he will lose the g5 pawn at the end
of this trade
so queen captures on c3 we have real
characters and rook captures and g5
would
check knight to g3 and now knight to f6
so here
maxine is down upon and uh well
his pieces are active will he be able to
hold this let's
let's see what happened king to f1 first
he on pins now the knight can move we
have
rook to b8 uh and now uh h3
we have rooked e5 a very strong move and
now both of
both of his rooks are on the only two
open files on the board
so uh it makes sense to position them
like this and
if white wants to trade you you really
don't care uh
then your bishop gets here you attacked
the rook and also yeah you're
you're up upon you wanted the rooks of
the board you
you want to fight with with minor pieces
not have the rooks on the board
so here we have bishop the c4 uh just
getting that
bishop out of the b3 square so it's not
under attack and also you
add support to the rook we have rook to
c5 now
now the bishop cannot move as this rook
would be under attack
and now rook c to c2 we have looked at
a5 now attacking this pawn
and here's the problem for maxime uh now
maxine cannot
keep defending both of his pawns because
if he goes rook to a2
then this rook attacks the pawn and the
bishop and now he's going to lose the
second pawn as well
so here we have knight the e4 that's our
knight the e4 by white
uh and now maxime trades with uh sorry
deck trades we have uh knight captures
rook captures
and rook captures an a for grabbing the
second pawn as well
uh we have h4 by maxime now at least
trying to to give up another pawn to
mess up black spawn structure
but now we have came to g7 uh h5
we have g captures on h5 this is
correctly
correctly captured we have rooked e1
and the nokia's rook beat the b4
attacking the bishop here we have bishop
to e2 and
now rook to h4 with the idea of rook h1
check you just want to
trade down you're up two pawns so we
want to trade down as many
pieces as possible because if everything
other than the king and the pawns uh
disappears from the board then of course
black is completely winning he's up
three pawns so bishop to f3
and here black just played a5 and it was
in this position
uh unmov 44 that maximum shield resigned
to the game as there is nothing more to
be done here
uh he can prolong the game he can try
something but it's not one pawn it's not
two points it's
three pawns so the this is really
unplayable
so a really amazing stuff and it's uh
incredible how how
dick is uh destroying these top guys
like i said the first two rounds are two
of the members of the candidates
tournament 2021
and uh he almost had two wins so he he
had a winning position against gilroy
now he
he beats maxine uh maxim was playing
brilliantly
uh for for the entire game but then that
one point where he should have seized
the initiative
uh by bringing the the queen to
the e6 he brought he brought her back
and that was all that it took
after that rook to f5 move here after
queen to d3 this
after this rook to f5 move it was all
black there was no way for maxine to
bounce back
so great stuff and uh congratulations to
the young grandmaster uh bogdan daniel
deck on his uh
impressive second game and we'll see if
he will be able to continue
playing in this uh great style for the
rest of the tournament
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it uh i would like to thank tom daralow
fred ackerman
peter rademoski dexter and david kimura
for contribution to my channel thank you
a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world so thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day